hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play a loosest
Louis's well lookie here
I found a pile of dirt I in a jar of
dirt I get a jar of dirt I get a jar of
dirt and it's look at look at what
inside it okay I found a pile of dirt
outside the back of the mayor's house
which means that I found the third
symbol but I discovered that there are
actually five pieces ah oh you gotta be
joking me what where did that [ __ ]
dog oh you gotta be joking me this
stupid ah time fine I'm fine I didn't
hear it and hear it behind me thought
I'd be safe while I was away no I got it
where is it where is it where is it good
yeah get away I got to throw something
ba had a shovel in my hand I need to uh
you guys told me I need to throw rocks
at these things so fighter noon I could
throw ice Adam ah ie Barranca whatever
okay here's a rock no that's not a
grabbable Rock though it's not good
enough to pick up that rock dude there's
not a single rock here that I can pick
up is there yeah Lee Park who are going
I don't want any I don't want to deal
with you right now I got a deal with a
guy I can't deal with you a guy I deal
with the guy I got to deal with
everybody that's trying to jump my bones
here here Rock yes get ready we'll be
good
hahaha
I got you good
I got good I got you good oh you want
some more you want another Rock I got
plenty of rocks won't be as hard to find
Rockets will be to find it out dirt I
guess I'm dirt here you want some rock
you want a rock in your face you want a
rock in your face you want to rock it
Neil oh and your face yeah I'm asked
stupid rock
budget juices give me good hairdo doctor
hey hey I got him go on oh no oh no oh
no
give me a rock give me a rock give me a
rock give me rock you know huh haunt you
in the head shouldn't that have stopped
you no don't kill me I got to get back
up into the temple or something
I forget what I gotta do I gotta get a
theater but he can't get money behind me
take it away behind me oh come on give
me a rock c'mere Rock I got now two
things chasing me how is this fair how
is this fair you are [ __ ] I will oh
yeah you better run that's what I
thought stupid son of a gun son of a
nugget biscuit no yep no get biscuit oh
man how's that song go I don't even
remember mother that's a tobyturner song
but I can't remember how it goes I
listened to that a long time ago yo your
[ __ ] good nugget in chicken in the bit
I don't even know nugget in the biscuit
dig it in oh man rotator I don't
remember it's been so long whatever it
doesn't matter all the matters is how to
get to this temple wait a minute I don't
even need to go the temple I need to go
to the amphitheatre or whatever the
stupid thing was with the stupid seats
and the stupid cutscene that maybe get
stupid killed how do I even get rid of
the other guys long enough to be able to
go over there this is all dumb they're
sealed and own team to work it no work
okay there's a stone pillar below
there's nothing here for me
whatever I'm going to the theater with
that douche if that douche tries to mess
with the likes of me
wasn't I running away from a wolf over
here the wolf just aside to meet up with
me earlier than usual everything in this
game is against me but I'm gonna skip
ahead here because I said that I was
gonna get through this quickly I don't
know if he'll be able to finish this
game in one episode but I'm gonna cut
out as much fluff as possible so be back
in a minute
ah okay all right some douche ghost is
over there why why did I need to come
here I don't think there's anyone behind
me I think that I'm actually safe I just
spit on my screen what was that guy
doing what do you doing you stupid ghost
Oh looks like he hit something what is
it it's a cylindrical extrusion on the
bottom a plate with a cylindrical
extrusion all right then
whoopee fricking new so whoa oh the
effects of the drink have officially
worn off well good it was a bit too blue
anyway so now that we are here we need
to find before we do anything we need to
find the other pieces and the other
piece that I have not gotten is I got
written down over here some above the
theater I would have totally gone the
wrong way it's above the theater I know
this is like I don't usually cheat like
this but I just it would be impossible
for me to find these if I if I didn't
have a reference here so I only have the
reference for the last two stone parts I
actually found the mayor's one bamaca
jerk ah
hahaha I found the dirt it's gonna be a
wolf is in there you better save okay
put this away yes it's saved get out
here
no Wolfie no Wolfie no Wolfie this is
good this is a good thing and by the way
is it ever gonna be day it's been night
for quite some time now I feel like it
needs to turn but anyway the last one is
on the side path - da da da I was
reading a ring hey you won't get me cuz
lipid ow oh did that hurt did that hurt
you ha Wow
what's they even the point what's even
the point if it doesn't do a thing God
dang it
gage Jean a URI fine I'm just gonna I
got to get back to that this is I gotta
get back to the beginning of the game Oh
towards the village entrance and then I
get get back there and it'll be fine and
then I'm gonna pick up this rock and I
smash him in the skull until he falls
over he's got a torch I've got a rock
and frankly his robes look pretty
flammable to me so if I were to grab him
bash him with this rock take his towards
and light his ass on fire I think I
might have a better time of this oh you
don't want to be here all you heard I'll
go smash his head in with this rock oh
now he doesn't want to play whoo-hoo
uh-oh feel a big baby
but John whiny baby I thought that light
might have been a torch these Sons of
Guns don't think that they can mess with
me the likes of me have an unseen by
them heck this village looks like it
hasn't seen anything in quite a few
years so why not okay so it's a side of
the path go back to the road where the
car is and walk back to the village from
the beginning of the past count four big
trees on your right after the fourth one
turn right and go to a big one what the
hell
I gotta get four trees from the right
from the beginning of the path John big
trees not small trees big trees this
totally obscure and I must have walked
by this place before this is stupid
so I'm on the lookout for a giant
boulder big old Boulder where's the
beginning of the damn path is that a big
old Boulder that looks like a big ol
Boulder to me let's go check
is there a derby it's a pile of dirt it
looks so dirty hey you do yeah finally
the dirt is mine I have all five symbols
Oh also I swung by the cemetery ah shut
up rats but it saved it saved it did
save after that point I saw it as I'd
save I saw it save how many times have I
died stupid even a wolf you know a wolf
is a pretty deadly creature but one is
not you can tandel one wolf well I don't
know who you are but I could handle one
wolf I need a rock give me a rock
give me a rock Devin I mean I wouldn't
be I wouldn't be out of it without a
scratch on me I'm not saying like huh I
picked that wolf to town and he wouldn't
even know I hit him no I'm saying like
you can you can unless it gets your neck
I guess but don't let it get your neck
that's bash it in it all smash elbow
smash it down into the ground
whoo I'm not then go out randomly and
God and find wolves and mad no no don't
do that don't don't take advice from
markiplier in that regard but I'm just
saying
mash it if it comes up if you get it
never mind don't take advice from
markiplier about life or anything rather
anything I say is wrong just assume that
assume that generally from the get-go
that I am wrong about everything because
I have been wrong so far and I am going
to f you up oh you heard that I was
gonna light your ass on fire ah
on fire I didn't get him very good did I
ain't gonna get me because I'm already
over moves to the temple and once I get
in this temple I don't know what's gonna
happen but I'm gonna see the end of this
game soon ish
I hope maybe hmm I don't even want to
mess with anyone right now because I
would just punch a baby in the face
punch it right in the face
don't let me near any babies Oh what am
i I'm some kind of monster I give
horrible advice I punch babies in the
face oh I'm horrible who cares about all
the charity I've raised I'm just a
horrible person god I'm awful bunch of
kittens to Seoul whole box full of
kittens poor jabal in the face each
one's Wow yeah that's what I do
cuz I'm crazy I'm crazy nutso alright
enough shenanigans enough lollygagging I
sure I brought you two just cut that
part out but I'm gonna leave it in
because I'm integrity and whatnot
okay so I'm guessing something goes here
the thing with the thing do I got to put
something in the thingy what do I do
well that didn't even good oh maybe I
got a hand
oh no way that's why I got the lighter
food I gotta let this [ __ ] on fire good
thing I picked up these matches from me
I swear I didn't know that I needed
those I just picked them up because I
accidentally went to the cemetery
instead of the theater wall during the
cut seriously I didn't know that I need
that but I'm so glad I did okay what do
we have here
Oh most babies laden Naboo la me the moo
shu ami faint lines on the map oh I
gotta go back to the mayor's house and
see the map okay whatever
Curt chunk put it who broke this anyway
what kind of douche went through all
this trouble of bearing this just so
that I would find them and put hell no
this looks expensive
am I the Tomb Raider of this strange
place maybe okay I found a weird device
what do I do with the weird
vice hi
no oh I'm hiding again this is gonna
work ah yeah hi guya back why now
why are your torch now got you uh down
into the ground
I should take his robes and wander
around the woods like one of him I am a
monster this guy was like I'm just going
to the temple to pray that this monsters
goes away and I'm like where's the
blacksmith bonk
what give me your key it's just the key
to the blacksmith Aiona gonna ply McKean
where's the blacksmith wha okay uh I'm
done I'm done being a psycho crazy
person or am i I've never done okay so
wait a minute where did wait I thought
didn't I pick up that star thingy I
thought it was supposed to go to the map
or do or do I Oh what does that mean oh
that's telling me the locations of the
dirt piles well that doesn't make any
sense at all because was I was able to
open all when I get the amphitheater I
was supposed to go back to the temple
and that would have told me where I
didn't need this guide on an idiot okay
that shows like the exactly okay alright
whatever okay so where do I take this
the only other place that I haven't been
is this area up here really so if I go
back that way what's over here first let
me just make sure that I haven't got I
haven't missed anything over here don't
think I have cuz when I went in here
didn't a wolf pop out when I came out
yeah I think so I think so I think so
okay so don't need to do that but what
do I need to do now huh what do I need
to do now I have a strange device a no
idea how to use it so the
only a place that I could possibly think
of it to go to that area that I have in
bed before so yeah because wait have I
been there I'm not sure I'll be back as
soon as I found out what I need to do so
all right so you guys can join me again
I'm back on this path going towards on
this is the dead end where I found the
other guy I did come back here before
but um I'm thinking that might have been
something here though
maybe I actually I might be wrong I'm
everyone oh what's that
a strange spiral symbol away hang on I
knocked out one of them comes a key
attached to a prayer rope where could I
use this key I have no idea where I
could use it the church it was rosary
beads weren't they oh man I knew that
okay let me before
oh oh oh rosary beads of course the
church I got to go back to the church
that poor guy was just praying that I
wasn't pleased with the monster go away
please he probably wasn't with his
family and they were like Oh daddy
please help us we can't oh the monsters
gonna give don't worry kids I will
venture out and take care of him all I
have is a torch yeah but then he kept
hitting me in the head with a rock and
now I must go to the temple to try to
pray oh and now he's dead horse knocked
out I know he might be dead Oh either
way I'll be back
temple Oh flag alright we're back in
town
sorry for the delay I should realize
that from the get-go I saw they were
rosary beads it just didn't connect them
I had at least I hope this is right okay
let's do this wait what's that
oh oh how many of those placements could
I possibly open maybe there were houses
that I could have opened all over the
place
yes who's in here some family where's
your blacksmith where's the blacksmith
hello author other babies children
fighting down here her all right let's
try this thing I cannot use this here
they don't want ah there must be a place
to put this somewhere there's some book
painting st. George sanshin strange
removal okay
welp I guess this is the end of the road
for me cuz this is dumb maybe outside
somewhere I could have maybe somewhere
somewhere there's gotta be something
there's got to be some where in the
world have I seen a place to put
whatever this is whatever this is how in
the hoenn how uh uh alright this must be
the item they were searching for but why
why why all right I'll be back he'll
figure this out oh it was so simple oh
it's the only other inventory item I had
oh that took me way longer than it
should have okay we're going down we're
going down we're gonna we're gonna get
this is there a family hiding out here
Oh where's the blacksmith ha ha where's
the blacksmith ha chapter three uh-huh
oh come on this is ridiculous okay I
thought I was getting close to the end
but barely hey what's doing okay so
apparently I thought I was near the end
of the game but apparently I am not so I
will end it here and I will finish it up
in one more episode you will see the
ending in the next part so or maybe I
have no idea how long the game is but I
thought I was getting close
anyway so thank you everybody so much
for watching click the annotation for
more reviews it I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye
Moctar
love
haha
yeah